we're going to look at the possibility
of mix and matching vaccines
health agencies are exploring what
happens if someone who got the pfizer
vaccine tries a booster from another
drug maker like moderna
or j and j that could widen the net for
countries to eliminate
variants and europe just unveiled its
first hydrogen-powered trains
we're going to speak to one of our
reporters about to ride the train as
european nations pour money into
companies developing battery and
hydrogen technology
of the future and how does earth day
look from
space we chat with astronaut chris
hadfield about the future of space
exploration
and who he believes is the most
influential voice for clean
energy good afternoon everyone it's
friday april 23rd i'm tim stenoveck in
new york and this
is take a break let's do this
[Music]
good afternoon everyone and thanks so
much for joining us today well u.s
vaccine experts are meeting right now to
review johnson johnson's coronavirus
shot
and debate whether it should be used
again in the u.s
the shot's been on hold for 10 days
after several cases of rare and serious
blood clots
at the same time experts are also
questioning the need for booster shots
it's
been about five months since vaccination
started here in the u.s
researchers are looking into whether or
not the vaccines can be mixed and
matched
for those booster shots here to discuss
all this and more is bloomberg law's
senior reporter jeannie bowman
genie thanks so much for taking the line
you often report on regulatory groups
um what are you expecting to hear uh
from um
from when it comes to johnson johnson
you know i've i've heard different
things i mean i think
part of the reason that um that they did
the pause was to look at the data and
see if they could identify more cases
um i know that uh ashish who's one of
the top experts said recently he expects
the pause to be unpaused
um as of friday and janet woodcock did
say when they first announced it they
only expect it to last a few days
and now it's been a week so um so i
guess we'll see um
but uh but i think a lot of people are
expecting vaccinations to resume
well we're just learning from our
colleagues angelica levito and riley
griffin that jnj
vaccine-linked cases more than doubled
to 15 that's according to
researchers and this is coming from a
recent report just minutes ago does that
change
in in your opinion the way that they're
going to handle this data i mean it's
still
a a small number of total cases given
the number of shots that had been
administered
i don't know if it will change the
ultimate outcome but it could perhaps
they could you know maybe make more
specific recommendations about
population groups
um or or advise that you know maybe
women
18 to 49 because i think that was the
case you know maybe take
a certain vaccine over another but you
know as as you pointed out i think it's
also
while um they did find a lot more cases
one that was part of the reason they did
the pause in the first place was to see
if they could find
more if there were more cases out there
than the six they had initially
identified and two
um while of course blood clots are never
good and um it's terrible that
that people died it is still important
to look at the denominator
and you're talking you are talking about
at this point i think 15 out of 6.8
million
um doses that were administered so so as
you mentioned it is
it is a rare um um
rare of occurrence it is and then among
the cases reported in the slides
prepared for the friday meeting of
advisors to the cdc
three patients died seven were
hospitalized and five
were discharged jeanne i want to talk a
little bit about one of your most recent
stories for
bloomberg law it talks about mixing and
matching
uh vaccines uh for the booster shot to
be specific right so this
this this idea would be that we
potentially need a booster it's
something that pfizer ceo albert boula
has talked about and pfizer has talked
about
they are studying it why is this an
important question to be asking though
well well because we don't know with
it does appear that the pfizer and
moderna and johnson johnson we do know
works against some of the variants but
you know as cases are going up
especially around the globe
um we could have the emergence of new
variants and the
b351 that was first identified in south
africa
has shown to work um
has shown to diminish the effectiveness
somewhat of the vaccine so we may need
potentially a booster shot
and so you know if one becomes available
and it's just one
and we don't know um but you got one
from say you've got a modern vaccine but
it's the j j booster that's available is
it okay to take that
and so we do need to study that to make
sure that you know
we can make definitive safety
recommendations do
when we when we say booster do you mean
it would be potentially identical to
the the initial shots that we get and
it's just called a booster because of
the period of time that passes between
the first
and second or the second and third well
so
so that would be um so for when i was
talking about a booster i was talking
about people that are fully
immunized and then um a vaccine that has
been
tweaked to maybe account for for the
variance so not
just not just another dose of pfizer
another dose of moderna
or another dose of jnj this would
actually be
some sort of specific booster shot that
would be meant to to go after some of
the variants that have emerged
right and they are studying that too um
i think in england
especially um since especially between
pfizer
and modernist specifically because
they're they were
made so similarly and they kind of use
the same
technology and the efficacy
are so similar i think those are the two
that are being more youth
more looked at in terms of second dose
but ultimately in the us
i think they are saying stick with the
science this is what we know
you should try to get you know a second
shot if you need one from what do we
know and what do we not know genie
because in
in your most recent piece you do talk
about comparing this to
the flu vaccine which has been studied
for years and taken repeatedly
over and over again right so i mean
you know these are newer vaccines and
but if you think about it when you get
your flu shot you don't necessarily know
um at least i i've never known what
company flu shot i've gotten
i have no idea of any type of vaccine
that i've ever gotten in my life except
for the cova vaccine
exactly so i you know that was one of
the questions was it will it be okay to
if we need if we need a booster and a
lot of the folks i talked to said we
probably won't need an annual flu shot
or sorry an annual coveted shot but we
may need a booster
you know three or four years down the
line but a lot you know as they said we
don't have that data and so it just
that's why nih is actually starting
these studies to answer those questions
that's a little bit different than what
we've heard from pfizer because what
we've heard from pfizer is that we could
need a
a booster within the first 12 months
right
yeah one of the things to note though is
that unlike
influenza um the uh the
coronaviruses don't mutate quite as
quickly
as an influenza virus and and that's
and that's part of the reason that some
immunologists think that we may not need
an annual flu shot and also because as
vaccines ramp
up and as more people get protected
there's the less
it decreases the likelihood that we will
that we will have
more mutations right because if more
people are vaccinated
that virus doesn't have anywhere to go
to mutate
that is the that is the goal here get
everybody vaccinated and uh the virus
doesn't have anywhere to go but
unfortunately worldwide we are a long
way from that bloomberg law senior
reporter
jeanne bowman jeanne thanks so much for
taking the time great to have you on the
show
well rapid deployment vaccine
collaborative or radvac is developing a
fast and cheap covid19 vaccine that can
be produced with minimal equipment and
skill
bloomberg news health reporter john
lowerman invited the chief scientist for
radvac over to his house to mix up some
vaccine
in his kitchen check it out
sounds like my friend preston's here
it only takes a few ingredients to make
a vaccine very
simply very you know spontaneously by
mixing them together the primary
delivery vehicle is called kitazin
which is a derivative of chitin which is
a
polysaccharide that makes shrimp shells
and insect exoskeletons
and then you have to treat it chemically
we're going to mix together cutazan
with uh with some other ingredients
these are synthetic peptides that are
made
on a peptide synthesis machine peptides
being little pieces of proteins that's
right and these are little pieces of
proteins that
we know are in the coronavirus are
similar to those within the coronavirus
that's right there's two different kinds
of peptides here there's t cell peptides
and then there's some b-cell peptides
which they're the parts of the virus
that are involved in interactions with
your immune system so the b-cell
peptides will elicit antibodies
and all it takes is a little stir plate
first thing i do
is sterilize the inside of that
beaker so that is the kite is underrated
that's
the mix of basically insects shells and
pinch fruit parts yeah right shim powder
yeah
so now this is a pipette you can dial up
uh very specific volumes we're gonna add
two milliliters of this t cell peptide
[Music]
now we're going to add the uh the ionic
cross linker with the the b cell peptide
that is done cover it up let it stir for
a few minutes
okay what evidence is there that these
vaccines work
well we have a lot of research evidence
that vaccines like this work on various
animal studies
and in human clinical trials how many
doses are in there that's about 20.
this is about 20 dollars that's about
20. it's like a dollar a day 50 cents a
dollar 50 cents a day
yeah but you could make this at scale
for a diamond freeze and less yeah
this is an open source free and open
source vaccine any
country any organization can set up
production
and just do it without any royalty
agreements without any contracts without
even asking us whether or not
you know we approve of it i'm going to
take this vaccine i'm actually not going
to administer
the vaccine out of the spray bottle i'm
just using the spray top
as a sprayer to get the vaccine on my
nose i'm going to spray
into the vial it just makes sure that
i'm
dealing with uh sterile receptacles and
and sprayer
take some of the next scene
nose is fairly clear now i'm ready to
administer the vaccine
[Music]
and that's it
thank you to bloomberg's john lowerman
for opening up his kitchen to be a lab
for that one
and as john mentions in his
bloomberg.com reporting the vaccine
isn't proven to work and it doesn't have
regulatory
authorization it also hasn't gone
through huge lengthy costly clinical
trials like those
that have been undertaken by moderna
pfizer astrazeneca
and johnson and johnson now we don't
want to bear the lead on the rest of the
day's top news so here are some stories
we do not want you to miss
it's the end of a boom caused by the
pandemic kimberly clark has cut its
forecast
after a plunge in toilet paper sales
overall sales were down 8
last quarter meanwhile the company is
getting squeezed by higher manufacturing
costs
kimberly clark is raising prices by mid
to high single digits on a scott's
tissue business
and diapers and that proposed capital
gains tax hike is blamed in part for
driving down bitcoin for the seventh
time in eight days
the world's largest digital currency
dropped below the 50 000
mark bitcoin set its record of almost 65
000
back on april 14th
and new home sales in the us bounced
back last month to the highest level
since 2006.
that suggests that the housing market is
back on track after winter storms hurt
demand in february
purchases of new single-family homes
rose almost 21 percent to an annualized
pace of just over 1 million that figure
was
higher than all forecasts in a bloomberg
survey
you can always learn more about these
stories and stay up to date on today's
news at bloomberg.com
well coming up kurt schilling's 150
million
dollar failure we're back in two minutes
talking
video games this is take a break
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things
everything you need to know about our
changing environment the politics of
global warming
we can and we will deal with climate
change in the fight against climate
change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to take a break i'm tim
stenovec in new york
video game studios are risky ventures as
at bloomberg's jason schreier's new book
press reset
explores take the case of retired
baseball pitcher kurt schilling who
tried building a wildly ambitious game
to compete with
the mega hit world of warcraft that
turned out to be a flop for his gaming
company which went bankrupt
150 million dollars in debt
or the high turnover rate at game
developers take two interactive and ea
a survey of approximately one thousand
game workers shows that
most had at least two jobs in the past
five years
here with more is jason schreier himself
jason thanks so much for taking the time
congratulations on the new book it comes
out on may 11th
um why is curt schilling's story with 38
studios a good example
of the video game industries broken
system
hi tim thanks so much for having me so
uh i think kurt schilling's story is
is hard to believe for a lot of reasons
it's bonkers for
for many different reasons but in this
book press reset what i tried to do was
i tried to capture
and kind of answer the question of why
does this video game industry that is
making so much money
have so much trouble keeping its workers
happily employed and stable and
um prevent them from burning out and i
think her chilling story
is kind of a good case study for that
because this is a company that
had insane amounts of money 150 million
dollars as you mentioned
um it was run by a baseball player who
had made more than 100 million dollars
over the course of his career yet it
still managed to flame out
and leave employees holding the bag i
mean at the end of things when they
when they ran out of money as as today's
bloomberg article shows
um people were left they didn't even get
their final paycheck they were cut off
from their health benefits they were
laid off
abruptly in the middle of may 2012 um
they just found themselves screwed and
it
is kind of it it is exemplary i mean
it's a it's a
an anomalous story in some ways but it
also kind of
reflects the instability that is so
common unfortunately across the entire
video game industry
which is something that my book explores
jason it's a huge shift from when the
company started because in
in this excerpt that i that in bloomberg
business week it it talks about
you write about how the company was
actually trying to attract employees to
rhode island and one way that it would
do that
was by actually taking over the
mortgages on employee homes if they
lived in another state
if they couldn't actually sell their
home take us into some of the other
things that
that schilling was doing that wasn't
necessarily the type of thing that would
happen
at any company yeah this was a person
who had been an mlb player for many
years
and he was treated like an all-star
because he was an all-star and so
he would get the highest end everything
highest then benefits and
and salary and um perks massages ice
baths whatever and he wanted game
his game employees to have the same
treatment and so he would get people
high-end gaming laptops he would get
them the best possible health insurance
he would
do what you just said which is pretty
remarkable that when they decided to
move from boston to rhode island because
they got a loan guarantee from the state
of
rhode island for 75 million dollars in
exchange for moving there and
and bringing a bunch of jobs to
providence um he decided hey
we are going to help anyone who can't
sell their house we are going to pick up
their mortgages our company
and um we are going to pay those
mortgages until those homes are sold
so that we can make sure everyone moves
to rhode island and all of these things
these were things that in chilling's
mind
had to be done including the top
salaries bloating the executive ranks et
cetera et cetera but
ultimately it's what wound up leading to
the company just running out of money in
i i believe they blew through the
majority of their loan and all the money
they had in just a year after moving to
rhode island
and by may of 2012 schilling was trying
to
trying to put one ditch one last ditch
effort together he was
he believed that with enough persistence
he would be able to do it just like he
had
back when he was playing baseball and he
had that the infamous story of him
pitching and winning the world series on
bloody socks his ankle was so
messed up that it was bleeding through
his socks yeah so so this is like a guy
who believed in persistence and grit
and as a result of that he uprooted
destroyed the lives of hundreds of
people
how did he get into video games and and
and why was it that he thought
as as he said in the past and you write
about that he could get
bill gates rich by building his own
blockbuster game
yeah well so he he had obviously made a
lot of money he was worth
many many millions of dollars um and he
was obsessed with
um games because he would take his
laptop with him on the road whenever his
his uh buddies his teammates would go
out to bars he would just be staying in
his hotel playing a world of warcraft um
or like everquest was
was his favorite he would say that uh he
wanted to stay out of trouble
uh and not not go off and not not get in
trouble with his wife
um and he was really into games and he
thought he like was talking to some
buddies online and he decided hey
i think i could do this i think i could
start a company that could take on world
of warcraft i could be
one of the biggest mmos ever um and to
do that he decided hey i'm going to
hire all of the top people in the video
game industry and bring them all out
here and
and and woo them all over the way that
the yankees and the red sox would just
hire the best the biggest baseball
players um
and yeah i mean it was it was this
mixture of like his hubris and his
arrogance and
his kind of not knowing what he didn't
know
um which can work out in some ways but
in this particular case it just
exploded in in really spectacular
fashion
you initially were able to
arrange to speak with schilling but that
ultimately didn't happen
he uh ultimately didn't did not want to
participate right
yeah i don't know if i if it was well so
i
i had been texting with him i'd been
messaging him he initially agreed to an
interview then just kind of stopped
responding
um tried to get in touch with him a few
more times and he was just off and on
off and on
sometimes he would take weeks and weeks
to respond to a message and be like oh
yeah sure i'll talk
and then when i would try to schedule a
time it just worked out um
i don't know if it was him actively
saying actively not wanting to
participate or just him
that's just his natures or maybe he's
just a busy guy i don't know but
ultimately he was not able to i was not
able to
um sit down with him uh for the story
so without giving away the entire book
jason i
know we can't do that in an interview of
course but but give us a takeaway for
people here
about what what makes a video game
company work like if you were
if you were looking at the successful
ones not the ones that that
run by kurt schilling are the ones that
have exploded what is the common thread
that makes them work
yeah i mean video game companies so in
my book press reset i actually look at a
bunch of stories of
companies that didn't work unfortunately
um and i actually think
it's really there's no real secret sauce
there's no like one
answer um for these game companies to
work and in fact one of the themes that
i explore in this book is that
um even the companies that seem
successful uh ultimately might not be
um one of the other companies that i
cover in press reset is called
irrational games
and they're the company that made it a
series called bioshock that was very
well known
critically acclaimed massive success
they released a game called bioshock
infinite in 2013 which i talked about in
the book
and then a year later they were gone
they were shut down suddenly a hundred
people were out of jobs
and this thing is all too common this
type of trend is all too common in the
video game industry
game developers do not have the kind of
protections that many other
industries have they don't have unions
they don't have any sort of
leverage when it comes to dealing with
with management and
it's just an epidemic that leads to so
many people burning out and just leaving
the video game industry entirely
there's a lot of brain drain in gaming
unfortunately
so yeah i wish that i had brighter news
and i could say
here is how to make a successful video
game company but really there are a lot
of problems that the
this industry needs to tackle head on
in order to make a sustainable
environment for its workers
bloomberg's jason schreyer jason we're
going to have to leave it there thank
you so much
for your time congratulations on the
book as i mentioned his new book press
reset
ruin and recovery in the video game
industry comes out on may
11th well coming up next wall street's
biggest banks are pledging trillions of
dollars in sustainable finance
one perk they're going to save billions
of dollars in taxes
we're back in two minutes this is take a
break
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
lumber prices across the u.s are
skyrocketing a 60
surge this year sent prices to a record
and analysts
they aren't expecting any relief until
late 2021.
if you can get your hands on it you're
going to buy it no matter what the
number is
and the numbers are getting higher and
higher futures have a
daily limit but in the cash market where
i trade
there is no limit and prices are going
up significantly
tightness is acute across the entire
timber supply chain
sawmills have had trouble ramping up
fast enough to meet demand
while trucking delays and worker
shortages at lumber yards have added to
the cost
the summer peak of u.s home building is
expected to deepen these supply
constraints
and keep home prices red-hot what's
happening is
lumber's going up uh insulation's going
up stucco is going up
concrete's going up and that's getting
passed on to the consumer
according to the national association of
home builders wood costs
have already added more than 24 000
to the price of the average new house
the unexpected boom in demand
buoyed by the pandemic that sparked a
wave of diy
projects around the house full-scale
home renovations and in many cases
purchases of bigger homes redfin data
showing housing demands so fierce that
almost half
of the u.s homes out there are selling
within a week of hitting the market
lumber prices are expected to stay
elevated for months to come
that was bloomberg's remain bostik with
a look at how extreme america's shortage
of lumber has become
welcome back to take a break i'm tim
stenovec in new york
meet wall street's new trillion dollar
club and it's all about esg
or environmental social and governance
jpmorgan chase bank of america
citigroup and morgan stanley have all
pledged six trillion dollars in
sustainable finance
and the billions that they're going to
save in taxes is one of the big benefits
here to discuss is at bloomberg's
finance reporter max abelson max always
great to have you
on the show thanks so much for for
joining us so why are our banks making
these investments um
what's the main motivator here because
there are some pretty significant tax
benefits
that's right that's right well first of
all same here it's always always good to
be with you
okay so i'll take you back to january
january this year let's go back a little
bit
so bank of america puts out its fourth
quarter earnings report right as they
always do
in early january bury down there
is is a line a line or two of disclosure
where bofa says our 2020 tax rate
would have been 21 but thanks to esg
and that of course i'm sure your viewers
know but it's environmental
social and governance projects thanks to
esg
our tax rate is all the way down to 5.
wow bank of america said from 20 what
would have been 21
to 5.8 21 percent the tax rate that
corporations in the us are supposed to
pay
that that's right well it's not a matter
of what you're supposed to pay i mean
each company sort of
ends up with a different effective tax
rate i think that's fair to say um
depending on what's going on so there's
would have been 21
instead thanks to esg 5.8 so
uh executives at a at a large regional
bank see this
and they talk to a guy named brian
alprin uh and he is at faustin company
class and company is a tax specialist
and brian alperin uh is in charge of
what uh renewable energy there
and and i talked to brian and he
remembered that the bank executives
said to him you know they're basically
whistling they're basically like you
know wow
would you look at that you know and
maybe we should be getting into this too
and what lenan my colleague and i wrote
about um
is that the big banks are really getting
into it
but is it actually something that
is good for the environment is it
actually something that is going to help
when it comes to the climate goals that
the us
and more so countries around the world
have yeah tim i mean i think it's
important to remember uh that there are
a couple couple of things going on so
first of all let's let's just quickly
talk about the numbers
so jp morgan this month two and a half
trillion dollars
uh over the next ten years bank of
america one and a half trillion dollars
then citigroup and morgan stanley a
trillion dollars each
and i'm bad at math but i think that's
like six billion dollars that's why
we're journalists
thank you thank you very much that
that's a that's a lot of money and i
think that
the analysts that we talked to said that
there are a couple of things going on
here
one of them is that you know peop
they're interested in doing some good
here you know i don't think we should
dismiss that
uh i think we should be skeptical as
journalists but i i what they said is
you have to embrace that they're trying
to do some good exactly tim as you refer
to
they're also trying to please regulators
regulators like seeing things like this
uh they're trying to impress
shareholders and activists and
of course they're trying to cut tax
bills that that this is a story about
all those things together
there's brett fleischman who who runs
the fossil fuel finance campaigns for
the non-profit 350.org uh who you and
lenan spoke to
for this piece said that wall street to
turn should turn its attention
somewhere else right rather than these
pledges they should be focused on
getting fossil fuel companies uh for
phasing out rather uh their support of
fossil fuel companies
that's right what's the case that he's
making important thing that's that's
what brett fleischman from from the
nonprofit said the single most important
thing banks can do
is is to stop financing uh fossil fuel
investments
and he's not alone um earlier this month
so you know all this stuff is is very
fresh that's a fun thing about writing
about this
esg it's all happening now earlier this
very month
investors who together manage 11
trillion dollars
came out and said we want the world's
biggest banks
to to phase out financing a fossil fuel
company so they're not saying
you have to stop today they're saying we
want you to phase it out
and to back the paris climate agreement
and you know for now
the banks um i think where the what the
banks are more interested in are things
like
um driving to net zero which jane
frazier
the new head of citigroup talked about
yesterday um
closing the gender pay gap promoting
racial equity um
and and then you know backing these
commitments because
the trillion dollar club is so far a
commitment about the future
so they they want to they're talking
about you know backing those commitments
with with
real action to quote jane frazier and
measurable results and that and that's
what we'll be looking at
in the years to come max to what extent
do retail investors and sort of everyday
investors actually
care or think about esg it's something
that we've heard a lot about it's
something that banks and
financial institutions like to talk
about right that millennials like us
are the ones who actually care where
they're investing um
is that something that you see is is
actually happening
look i mean i think that it's it's
important to
recognize that on the one hand when i
was writing this story here in my
apartment in brooklyn
i was thinking should i say esg
in the headline or should we say green
you know do people
do readers even know yes sheep right
just just for the record
just for the record yes she did make it
into the headline so we we
uh steve dixon our editor and i uh and
lynn
felt strongly enough that people do know
what esg is but you know
as far as how big it is and what's to
come
i think it's important to remember that
um city and morgan stanley
who were two to the companies that we're
talking about here you know joined i
think
40 plus banks um just just the other day
in signing a pledge and and what they
say is that they're going to cut
pollutions
from that from their portfolio they're
going to cut pollution from their
portfolio and reach net zero
net zero of emissions by 2050 which you
know
it's in 30 years from now right um that
this is part of
the glasgow financial alliance uh for
net zero which
mark carney the the old bank of england
governor uh is involved with
but you know it's it's obviously meant
to coincide with biden's
global summit uh this week it's it's
very much a big thing and it's very much
happening now max we're gonna have to
leave it there that's bloomberg finance
reporter max
abel abelson max have a great weekend i
look forward to chatting with you a
little bit later on bloomberg
businessweek radio thanks so much for
your time
well coming up hydrogen trains are set
to make their debut in europe in less
than a year it's also an industry that
morgan stanley predicts
will be worth billions of dollars over
the next 30 years we're back in two
minutes to explain why
this is take a break
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry uh buildings
electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing
environment the politics of global
warming we can and we will deal with
climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to take a break i'm tim
stenovec in new york well it's time now
for quick take by the numbers it's where
we give you the numbers that tell the
story
this afternoon's number is 10 there are
substantial growth prospects for
hydrogen trains in europe according to
morgan stanley analysts
they estimate that by mid-century the
sector could be worth between 24 billion
and 48 billion dollars
by 2030 trains running on hydrogen could
make up one in 10
or 10 percent of those not already
electrified
the french rail transport company alstom
which is known for its high-speed trains
such as the tgv
and eurostar expects more than 5000
passenger trains
running on diesel in europe will have to
be replaced by around 2035.
it also says a quarter of all trains in
the region
will use use the fuel and will have to
be retired
by around mid-century to meet climate
goals
european nations are already pouring
money into subsidies for companies
developing battery and hydrogen
technology for vehicles
this could also be extended to the rail
industry to replace diesel train
engines and starting next march train
passengers heading between uh
two areas in germany will be riding one
of the country's first hydrogen-powered
passenger trains
the debut will establish a toehold for
the technology in europe
bloomberg's tara patel reports on all
things transportation in paris and she
joins me now
tara thanks so much for for taking the
time eu lawmakers reached a deal this
week to make the blocks ambitious
climate goals legally binding
so how do hydrogen trains play into that
well for the moment i think i have to uh
to quote that
that child's book that i think i read
when i was about two the little little
train that could there's
a little engine that could that's right
i i have a two-year-old so i'm
very familiar with this
for the moment we're talking you see you
you
you mentioned all kinds of really really
big numbers in the introduction
and those um could become reality but
we're talking about decades away but for
the moment
starting in march there will be a little
train
a relatively small train uh going plying
a route
over about a hundred and twenty
kilometers along the coastline
of northwestern germany that will run on
hydrogen
and that means that the only exhaust
coming out of uh
out of the train will be water vapor hmm
why is hydrogen the right fuel for this
why not electricity electricity is also
an alternative
i think what the european union wants to
do and
a lot of these many state-owned railways
because that's how it really works in
europe
is to replace their uh
very polluting diesel uh powered or
fueled trains and the question is
whether they would do it with hydrogen
or electricity and this is something
that's also a question that's being um
being asked in the
in the vehicle market too because we're
seeing increasingly
uh hydrogen being used in delivery vans
and you know these small
projects so what morgan stanley points
out as well as
bloomberg new energy finance is that it
probably will depend
on the type of route longer routes
seem to lend themselves better for
hydrogen and very short
routes maybe for battery packs and then
you could also use
power lines but that's not always
possible for trains because
power lines are hard to run if you're
going a train is going through a
mountain or
very small tunnels hmm um you were able
to take
a a virtual tour of of this
of this train this this little this
little engine that could
um what was it like is it does it look
any different
than a typical train engine
no no it looks it looks a lot like a
typical
train engine the one that the one that
we were we were looking at
this week looks very much like a
regional train
so sort of you know a little a little
different from a subway but
but not too far off um and very modern
and very clean because i
you know i think that these trains would
be replacing some very
old uh models that have been uh
that have been on routes for for decades
you know
is is this something that would at all
affect the customer experience or
or or not at all because it's only the
way that it's propelled
and it doesn't even you know affect the
car that passengers are in
that's right well the one one thing that
but that the operator the german
operator
so an executive speaking for the german
operator who's actually bought the
trains
and is going to put it them into
commercial operation next year
as well as an austrian an executive
working for an austrian railway
um both commented that that passengers
were struck by how
quiet oh okay so even quieter than an
electric train
very very quiet well i suppose the
passengers were comparing it on these
trains
diesel engines that they were used to
you know trying to trying to adjust
their
their headphones when they're listening
to whatever they're listening to on
their daily commute
um but they're very quiet and they were
also struck by the um
by the fact that there was no uh
polluting emissions coming out of them
we have an interesting debate happening
here in the united states when it comes
to infrastructure
uh and and the role that trains play in
that and it's one that there is not
widespread
uh agreement on can you just give me a
general idea of
and really explain to viewers just how
essential trains are
uh people who maybe live in the united
states and just don't
haven't experienced the importance of
trains uh in europe and how much this
plays into the economy
that's right i mean in europe you know
the first of all the geography is
different
there are very very large cities the the
population density is much higher there
are very large
cities that that aren't very far apart
um
you know even though there's a there's a
body of water between paris and london
there's a train that that makes the
journey between paris and london in
under two hours
um you can cross france in a tgv
well almost between paris and the and
the riviera
riviera as well in in you know a little
over two hours
and so people for these these journeys
of on
two two and a half three hours even
longer people prefer to take the train
because it's city to city
it doesn't you don't have to you know
slap out to uh to an airport and
and you know at the time when when
airplanes were
still flying before the pandemic yeah
wait in lines and
go through customs go through security
um trains are are
secure especially if you're coming from
the city center much quicker rail system
is absolutely enviable
in europe bloomberg's tara patel in
paris tara thanks so much for your time
and have a great weekend
well coming up we're going to hear one
how one astronaut
views uh well he's passionate about
protecting the planet why he is
we're back in two minutes this is take a
break
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to take a break i'm tim
stenovec in new york well there are very
few people here on this earth who
know exactly what the four astronauts
heading to the iss right now
are feeling one person who does though
is retired astronaut and former space
station commander chris hadfield
exactly two decades ago on earth day
hadfield became the first canadian to
walk in space
truly witnessing for the first time as
he says the view of our planet
hadfield is also the author of an
upcoming thriller about the space race
he spoke with bloomberg quick takes
jennifer zabasaja yesterday
on earth day check it out 20 years ago
you were not on earth at this time just
talk to us about sort of what
what this moment means for you yeah
20 years ago this week i got to have the
incredible human experience of
seeing the world through nothing but the
plastic
of my visor i was outside on a spacewalk
my first spacewalk in fact what turned
out to be canada's
very first spacewalk we celebrated on
the back of our five dollar bill up here
but uh to be able to pull yourself
out of a ship and to be going around the
world
you know every hour and a half to cross
the states in 10 minutes from
l.a to new york you know see all of that
history and geography
to see all seven and a half billion
people all together
it was a huge personal experience but
it's also just an amazing way to think
about something
like the concept of world day and
i mean chris we're talking at a time
when world leaders are convening
uh to try and avoid a crisis here on
this planet and
you know as somebody who has a
completely different lived experience of
sort of what this planet
is how does that affect what you think
about when it comes to climate
change we have
really serious global problems to solve
but every generation does we just sort
of you know it depends on the size of
the world
10 000 years ago their world was smaller
they weren't
all seven and a half billion spread all
over but they had serious existential
problems and
you know if you go back 200 years gosh
the plagues that were rolling through
and half of all kids died by five years
old or
or the plague of uh of 1918 1919 that
killed three percent of everybody in the
world of the world wars
there are always enormous complex
existential problems for humanity on
earth the ones
that you mentioned the world leaders
dealing with climate change right now
obviously
this is one of the big ones facing us
how do we
feed what is eventually going to peak
out at around maybe 10 billion people
how do we feed them and provide fresh
water for them and
a decent standard of living and and
do it in a way that doesn't permanently
change the chemistry of the atmosphere
and the oceans
in this in a sustainable energy way
that's a really complicated problem
but you know we've solved problems
before
it takes creativity it takes cooperation
it takes vision
it takes patience all of those things
and having been around the world
you know 2 600 odd times
[Music]
i'm heartened and optimistic by the
toughness of the world and the toughness
of life
but also by our capacity when we need to
to work together
it's not going to be easy and we're
going to get it wrong a lot but
there are paths forward and we really
need to both trust
but also demand and enable our
leadership to do the right thing
right now what makes you optimistic
um i've had this strange vantage point
like the one i had 20 years ago when i
was on board a spaceship
we went from one side of the sun to the
other halfway around
the solar system and and in that time i
got to watch summer and winter swap ends
in the world
it was like you know as snows melted and
green appeared it's amazing to watch
over six months
but i realized it was like watching the
earth take one breath
out of four and a half billion breaths
and
how refreshing how tough how
self-healing
how incredibly resilient and
rugged our planet is and also the
realization that there has been life
uninterrupted for four billion of those
four and a half billion years on earth
so life is also tough and and
that's really reassuring you know there
have been some awful things happening in
the last four billion years
and yet life is still here earth is
still here and
it's really just a matter of can we
be responsible enough to recognize the
problems that are facing us
and then change change our own habits
change how we organize together
change how we do some of the things that
we've just sort of accepted as
the way we've always done things in the
past you know
we've done it before that we've rallied
to face horrific problems
that this is another one it's global we
have to find ways to cooperate when we
don't want to
but that doesn't mean we can't given
your vantage point
uh of the earth what are what are those
things that
people here on earth should be thinking
about uh in order to
protect the planet you know i think
people need
to recognize uh that that is
it is your own choices that then have
the rippling influences right do i drive
do i walk
what do i eat where does my energy come
from
um how much of how wealthy do i need to
be
how much work do i need to do on these
things how do i account for the other
living things around the world
you know individual choices uh really
matter
and and then how can you inform people
and give them motivations to to change
some of those choices
there's just such a classic example
going on with
what uh what you know elon musk is doing
for example
i can't think of one more influential
person on earth
who is shifting general public
perception
of some of the fundamental changes that
need to happen in
power generation i mean it's so nice to
be able to just turn the lights on
and not even think about where that
power came from but of course it has
large repercussions
how do we generate power how do we store
power how do we make all the things run
that make life good
like they never have before in history
for so many people
we just have to get to the fundamental
technologies
uh and and allow them and accept
their change in our regular daily habits
so that then
it doesn't have the irreversible
negative impacts
on the planet that are easily measurable
you know locally but even more so from
the satellites that are orbiting the
world
when we think about young people in the
next generation who are just so
passionate about
um you know changing the world that they
are going to be living in i'm
is there anything that you have learned
from this next generation um
and um what more do you want to teach
them and to share with them especially
given your own experience
oh yeah i i i'm luckily because of some
amazing technological advances
like the way that you and i are
communicating today or that using
uh the interconnectivity that we've seen
over the last year i hear voices that
otherwise i would never hear
and and obviously when you're born you
know nothing but you have a lot of raw
potential and as you get older
your world view gets more and more
informed but there's a tipping point in
there where you start
actually visualizing a possible future
and then making
personal choices about what's going to
happen and
the choices that i made young were
were based on a certain set of
expectations and
the generations that are growing up
right now
have a very strong different set of
expectations a different reality to deal
with
you know a different uh a set of
problems
and they're willing to address them
obviously they need to
it's not going to matter to me 30 years
from now what happens i'll be dead but
i'm really concerned about what my
granddaughter is going to be doing
and so uh i think we need to
give them the tools we need to give them
a clear understanding of the problem
and we need to provide some of the
technical solutions that will
enable a continued improvement of the
quality of life of people all around the
planet
and i'm i'm optimistic and heartened by
the
the way that uh the next generations
coming down the pike are addressing it
but the problem is not going to solve
itself if we don't
change the direction then we're going to
end up where we're headed right it's
pretty simple
and and so uh we need to
embrace that change uh at all different
levels
and and we need to give that as as an
enabling tool
and what essentially is a gift to our
children
well there you have it retired astronaut
chris hadfield speaking thursday with
quick takes jennifer zabasaja
well coming up is caitlyn jenner getting
into politics we're back in two minutes
this
is take a break
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry uh buildings
electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to take a break i'm tim
stenovect in new york well looking ahead
here's some stories to watch out for
this afternoon
in russia jailed opposition leader alexi
navalny says he's ending his hunger
strike
navalny began refusing food 24 days ago
that sparked concern that he could die
in prison
navalny gave up the hunger strike after
he was allowed access to outside doctors
and republican caitlyn jenner says she
will challenge california governor gavin
newsom in the recall election this year
jenner is an olympic gold medalist and
well-known transgender activist
newsom is a democrat who's been attacked
for the way that he's handled the
coronavirus pandemic
organizers have said they have more than
1.5 million signatures needed
for a recall vote that's gonna do it for
quick take this hour you can always
check out the latest stories at
bloomberg.com right quick take on social
media
i'm tim steineveck have a great weekend
everyone much more quick take at the top
of the hour
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good afternoon and welcome bluer quick
take where we bring you today's top news
and break down how it intersects
with the world of business coming up on
this afternoon show
we're going to look at the possibility
of mix and matching vaccines
health agencies are exploring what
happens if someone who got the pfizer
vaccine tries a booster from another
drug maker like moderna or j
j that could widen the net for countries
to eliminate
variance and europe just unveiled its
first hydrogen-powered trains we're
going to speak to one of our reporters
about to ride the train as european
nations pour money into companies
developing battery and hydrogen
technology of the future
and how does earth day look from space
we chat with astronaut chris hadfield
about the future of space exploration
and who he believes is the most
influential voice for clean
energy good afternoon everyone it's
friday april 23rd i'm tim stenoveck in
new york and this
is take a break let's do this
[Music]
good afternoon everyone and thanks so
much for joining us today well u.s
vaccine experts are meeting right now to
review johnson johnson's coronavirus
shot
and debate whether it should be used
again in the u.s
the shot's been on hold for 10 days
after several cases of rare and serious
blood clots
at the same time experts are also
questioning the need for booster shots
it's
been about five months since vaccination
started here in the u.s
researchers are looking into whether or
not the vaccines can be mixed and
matched for those booster shots
here to discuss all this and more is
bloomberg law's senior reporter jeannie
bowman
genie thanks so much for taking the line
you often report on regulatory
groups um what are you expecting to hear
uh from um from when it comes to johnson
johnson
you know i've i've heard different
things i mean i think part of the reason
that um
that they did the pause was to look at
the data and see if they could identify
more cases
um i know that uh ashish yahoo's one of
the top experts said recently he expects
the pause to be
unpaused um as of friday and janet
woodcock did say
when they first announced it they only
expect it to last a few days
and now it's been a week so um so i
guess we'll see um
but uh but i think a lot of people are
expecting vaccinations to resume
well we're just learning from our
colleagues angelica levito and riley
griffin that jnj
vaccine-linked cases more than doubled
to 15 that's according to
researchers and this is coming from a
recent report just minutes ago does that
change
in in your opinion the way that they're
going to handle this data i mean it's
still
a a small number of total cases given
the number of shots that had been
administered
i don't know if it will change the
ultimate out